The way we got around replication lag was
by having memcached. I think at the time--
Did we run memcached on the app servers
or that there is separate memcached boxes?
I don't know back then until very recently
there was no memcached on the servers.
Okay. There is memcached on servers now?
Yes.There is render cache on the servers
actually. >>Okay. Okay.
Now, there is a stable cache. >>Okay.
So, we transitioned, I think, over time.
I think when we started of memcached
was on each app server,
and then we started adding more and more app
servers, and the configuration got a little weird
because we'd bring up a new app server and do
you want to bring up new memcached server also
re-distribute the keys, so I think when
I left we had a bunch of memcaches
that were a separate cluster and
these are the memcaches.
We use memcaches at Reddit for everything.
It is like the Swiss Army knife of systems.
I think we used it definitely to avoid replication lag.
We'd write to the database and
memcached at the same time
so that when you do an immediate redirect to
a permalink page or something like that
the data is good to go, if your read
would've otherwise hit the slave.
The other big system we had and I think
this is kind of the final big system.
is we had what was called
as the precompute system.
Doing real time queries against database
was too slow to generate our listing pages.
So, we had a whole separate database
cluster called the precompute cluster,
which if I recall was just mirrored version
of all these machines,
and whenever you would submit a link to Reddit or
vote, we would submit a job to this Q.
The job would be something like update the
front page or update this person's liked page,
or all these different things like a vote
can--affects the front page,
it affects the new page, it affects your
liked listing, all that sort of stuff.
We put this job in the Q and then
what the Q would do is
it would say recompute that listing's front
page or recompute that listing's rising page
or recompute that users' liked page.
Some of them can be done in place
without actually hitting the database.
If you submit a link, we just put it
at the top of your submitted page.
You don't have to do anything fancy but it
also affects the htoness of that link, etc, etc.,
and we had a separate set of memcaches that were
actually running a technology called memcache DB,
and memcache DB is just like memcache
but instead of being totally in memory
it had a little disk datastore so it was
like kind of fast like memcache
because its mostly memory
but also would persist.
Data that got recomputed would be put in memcache
DB as kind of this middle-layer cache,
so we can avoid running queries on these databases.
That was basically the state of the system when I left.
Lots of replicated databases--this really
complicated precompute cluster.
We had this whole separate set of databases
that we could just run queries on
as hard as we could just one after another.
These machines were really sad all the time.
Actually, more specifically, they were literally on
fire all the time like these machines are hot. Right.
Because no query that the user would see
would actually hit these machines
so we could just beat the hell out of them, and
when the result is done, it hit this memcache DB
that's where we'd store the data,
and the users will only hit this,
so we would lose nodes here all the time
because we're abusing them.
We could add more. They can be slow. It didn't matter.
It was out of the actual request loop.
That took a lot of load off the whole system.